the Highland sisters left Dance Moms at
the beginning of season 4 and while
they've gone on to accomplish great
things fans have always wondered why
Paige and Brooke chose to call it quits
keep watching to find out if the
Hyland's chose to leave the show or if
they really got the boot these are my
two daughters this is Paige she's 10 and
Brooke is 13 it's no secret that Brooke
Hyland is a super skilled dancer whose
talent weren't being utilized during her
time on Dance Moms
Brooke was the oldest dancer on the show
and more often than not she appeared to
be bored
instead of giving her challenging dance
numbers and allowing her to dance with
girls her age Abby Lee Miller chose to
dim down her talents for the show in
truth however Brooke did actually dance
with girls her age
just not on Dance Moms on top of filming
the intense and time-consuming show
Brooke was also part of a different
dance group knowing this it makes sense
that Brooke came off as bored and tired
on the show because well she truly was
I'm not really sure about doing this
dance because Abby already hates us just
by dancing with a younger crew Brooke
did manage to receive a lot of solos
throughout her time on Dance Moms and
when she didn't kelly was quick to
confront Abby about her choices but the
same can't be said about Paige who
performed the least amount of solos out
of all of the original elite team
members this alone was enough incentive
for Brooke and Paige to one off the show
but not being challenged and receiving
little to no solos would be the least of
the Highland sisters worries as time
went on Abby Lee Miller became
frustrated with the girls claiming that
they lacked passion and drive and well
she wasn't exactly wrong Brooke was
losing her love for dancing so was Paige
I don't know what's going on with you
but you need to get your act together to
make matters worse Brooke felt like the
show's producers were painting her in a
bad light on multiple occasions Brooke
stated that the show strategically
altered her personality by editing the
footage so despite being a happy
teenager who was often seen laughing and
smiling she came up as stern unhappy and
bored on the air it didn't take long for
Kelly to realize that signing up for
Dance Moms had been a very bad idea her
girls were stressed beyond belief and
she didn't like the way Abby was
treating them
didn't have a lot of connections to get
these kids ahead I would have left a
long time ago
Kelly received a huge wake-up call when
her daughter Paige began suffering from
panic attacks and anxiety by now we all
know that Abby isn't the easiest person
to work with she's rude cutthroat and
incredibly opinionated and well not
everyone can handle being yelled at
during the rehearsals this was the case
for Paige who was so nervous when her
dance teacher was around that she often
fell victim to a panic attack and if
having a panic attack wasn't bad enough
the show's cameraman didn't know when to
back off they'd follow Kelly and Paige
wherever they went
which caused Paige to feel even more
stressed out in the end his time on
Dance Moms was so traumatic that the
young dancer had to see a psychiatrist
this all resulted in Kelly helping her
daughter file a lawsuit against her
dance teacher back in 2014
Paige claims that Abby was abusive and
that she often feared that she'd be
physically harmed surprisingly Paige
also stated that Abby used to pinch the
girls until they bled top that all off
with name-calling and bullying and the
Hyland's had a solid case right well not
exactly because before long the lawsuit
was dismissed the Hyland's had a handful
of reasons to leave the show but they
simply couldn't just get up and leave
Kelly and the girls had signed a binding
contract after all Kelly eventually
revealed that she and her girls hadn't
been a part of Abby's studio since
before the show started she claimed that
she agreed to appear on the show after
the producers reached out to her
however Kelly revealed that she quickly
realized she'd made a big mistake the
dance mom had been trying to get off the
show since season 1 but wasn't able to
break her contract Kelly Hyland always
had a bone to pick with Abby and she
wasn't one to back down
in fact she might even say that she was
one of the most entertaining Dance Moms
out of the bunch but for all of the
wrong reasons of course it stated that
the Hyland's were booted off the show
after their mother and Abby got into a
physical fight the big fight occurred in
season 4 episode 7 and it all started
when Abby told Kelly that her daughter
looked miserable and that Kalani should
take her place before proceeding to
point her finger in Kelly's face
escalated quickly when Abby started
trying to bite Kelly's finger which
resulted in Kelly scratching Abby's face
and pulling her hair the police were
called and Abby filed a lawsuit against
Kelly but Kelly struck back with a
lawsuit of her own Kelly's lawsuit
stated that Abby had tormented her for
years
Kelly went in depth about the time that
Abby referred to her as an alcoholic
stage mom to further this plane Kelly
referenced the time that Abby gifted her
eight bottles of tequila for Christmas
it's clear that Abby in the Hyland's
relationship was wearing thin which is
why mini fans weren't exactly surprised
when they left the show at the beginning
of season four this fight definitely
tipped the scale and resulted in the
Highlands being booted off the show this
was the first time that a mom had become
physically violent with Abby
sure they'd had their fair share of
screaming matches but this blowout was
something else I just report according
to TMZ Kelly was later arrested and the
Highlands left Dance Moms for good so
there you have it guys the real reason
why the Highlands left Dance Moms well
there were many reasons why Paige Brooke
and Kelly wanted off the show it was
Kelly's fight that terminated their
contract although Kelly states that it
was her decision to take her girls off
the show this isn't exactly true still
the X Dance Moms doesn't regret her
actions because they got her contract
terminated which is what she'd wanted
since season one before you go let us
know who you think started the fight in
the comments section below
was it Abby or Kelly and that's a wrap
don't forget to give this video of big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
thanks for watching we'll catch you next
time
[Music]